we know school teachers moms and dads  getting ready for next week but you know  what so is the ccsd's ginormous food  service department and they're offering  free healthy meals for all students and  that's not just breakfast and lunch it  includes dinner too  another dietitian work on menus  throughout the throughout the year and  we have to figure out okay does this  meet the nutritional guidelines of the  usda  are there any shipping issues because  we've all had tons of shipping issues  also  you know what new products are coming  out on the market  yeah a pizza  we have a lot more information about  this history's meal program check out  our website eight newsnow com